a huge manhunt is underway for the
gunman who killed a Texas law
enforcement officer assistant chief
deputy Clint Clint Greenwood was shot
early yesterday morning he served the
community for more than 30 years as both
an officer and as a defense attorney and
prosecutor police released this video
overnight officers believe it shows the
suspect vehicle leaving the scene Omar
Villafranca is in Baytown Texas at the
courthouse parking lot where the
shooting happened Omar good morning good
morning this is the spot where Greenwood
would pull up and park every morning
that spot there with the traffic cone
it's also the spot where a gunman killed
him police are now looking for a white
or Hispanic male about 6 feet tall with
short hair now the Houston Chronicle is
reporting the Greenwood emailed
officials recently and said he felt
threatened by a man he targeted in a
corruption investigation but at this
point they're not sure if the case is
related to this deadly shooting he was
on the ground and then I saw the cars
coming very quickly the deputies were
coming chief deputy Clint Greenwood was
gunned down shortly after arriving for
work Monday morning at the harris county
courthouse building in Baytown Texas
just outside Houston police released
this surveillance video showing a
suspect vehicle a small dark-colored car
Greenwood was airlifted to the local
hospital where he died any death is
tragic but it's even more tragic when
somebody that's sworn to protect the
public has their life tragically
shortened officers held a prayer circle
in tribute to Greenwood just yards from
where he was killed I just can't imagine
anybody wanting to shoot Clint Greenwood
Jim leitner works in the Harris County
District Attorney's Office he worked
with Greenwood in multiple departments
over the years from everything that
appears that it was an assassination so
it doesn't appear like it was a random
shooting investigators say the motive is
still unclear as far as whether or not
he was specifically target orbitz
because
the uniform he was wearing or because
the place that he pulled up to two in
the morning we just don't know that
right now first thing I thought about
was his family and his wife and his kids
Brian Behnken worked with Clint
Greenwood both as the defense attorney
and a prosecutor they even opened up a
law practice together everybody talks
about what a great law enforcement
officer he was what a prosecutor he was
and more than that he was a great family
man he was just he was a wonderful human
being there is a sixty five thousand
dollar reward that leads to information
that may lead to an arrest and charges
57 year old Greenwood leaves behind a
wife and four children Gail that's
always the hardest part of that story
here's hoping for an arrest in that case
very soon thank you very much Omar